you
as we've seen yahoo yet it's been 10
years since sister car maker said twin
impose o teamed up with Toyota to bring
a compact model on the market given the
low profit margins and high development
costs in the a segment says Sasha this
kind of collaboration pays off the three
car makers originally teamed up to
create the Toyota AYGO in 2005
alternatively badged as the Citroen c1
and the pooja 1079 years down the road
it's time for a new addition we're
testing the pooja 108 which rolled off
the assembly lines at the joint planning
clean and the Czech Republic the 107 is
sold eight hundred fifty thousand units
in total and is an important project for
P joke around sixty percent of buyers
are women so with the updated model Cujo
is expanding the color spectrum and
offering a range of custom options akin
to what opel did with the atom
the exterior the 108 differs
significantly from its it when and
toyota siblings that's a change from the
107
stickers to add dashes of color to the
interior and exterior costs 390 euros
upwards
chadha notice I should be moans the fact
that the stickers will probably only
last three to five years given their
price there are waste of money in his
eyes that Toya and I need for st. to
skate that in persona dr. 5-door version
castle 11 and a half thousand euros even
though it doesn't have any more space
than other models victim earflaps that
we skipped gansu Headroom is also an
issue when the hip toss ladder even with
the optional sunroof Headroom in the
back is insufficient only kids would be
comfy here somebody says I'm flats
maxima for clinic in de does column the
trunk space has been increased even if
it's still not superlative the trunk can
hold 196 liters of cargo and simply by
folding down the back seats that can be
expanded to 780 litres the car we tested
cause close to fifteen thousand euros
for that price you get all the trimmings
and a more powerful engine still the 108
maxes out of 170 kilometers an hour
octal Sasha points out that the 1-liter
3-cylinder Toyota version only costs
8890 euros although that the engine
design is 9 years old the total system
and Cujo offer an optional 1.2 pure tech
engine with 60 kilowatts unnecessary
improvement reckon Sasha notice if you
compare the engines it quickly becomes
apparent that neither is first-rate but
they are economical and that's what
counts for a city-run about sasha is why
someone would buy a pooja 108 instead of
its sibling vehicles because it looks
the best joke cujo's product press
director but he goes on to list a number
of arguments the models have stylistic
differences and the 108 is a true pujo
in terms of the front and the back this
is clearly a car in the pooja design
tradition he promises and it fits well
with the company's model family pojo
offers a broad palette of 108
customizing options covering everything
from the bodywork to the interior
customers get numerous possibilities for
creating their own personal 108 these
young who knocked individuals understand
couldn't our verde pooja 10 eights
handling is beyond reproach the steering
is good as are the comfortable seats
although they could offer some side
support the pre-show 108 is available
for 8890 arrows for that you get an
agile little city runabout but that's
all you can expect the optional 1.2
liter motor is a must to pep up the car
a bit otherwise it's good value for
money as are its sibling cars ones on
the Moodle not sure lives
Suzuki put out its compact sx4 and an s
cross version the car maker promised the
sx4 s-cross would combine a crossover
with off-road capabilities due to
popular demand the s-cross comes with
all-wheel drive however if history is
anything to go by this model will most
likely just be driven on roads but it's
also just a comfortable ride
cartas de manuel Schaefer says the
suspension gives it a smooth drive but
he thinks that with an S cross model
that's to be expected unfortunately the
car's interior has a bit of a
utilitarian feel the Ulf go emmanuel
says the interior is uncluttered a bit
too uncluttered he thinks the
manufacturers use too much plastic of
course Suzuki isn't just about interior
but functionality as well nothing is too
much everything's where it belongs even
the air conditioning and clunky gps work
well there's a special dial just next to
the gear stick Manawa explains that you
use the dial to select the driving mode
the first is snow mud for an unpaved or
slippery surface the second is sport for
those who want to drive fast and then
there's automatic and this mode the card
chooses the right mode for you with 118
horsepower this car does 0 to 100 km/h
in 13 seconds and consumes 4.4 litres
per hundred kilometers it also has a
good turning circle of ten point four
meters and in summer owners of an S
cross can enjoy a panoramic sunroof and
Germany this test car with a 1.6 litre
diesel engine comes for a price of just
under twenty nine thousand euros that's
nearly 10,000 euros more than the
gasoline-powered version Amanda will
explains that in sport mode the engine
pulls a good amount of draft through so
it's easy to overtake above the s-cross
came out in 2013 the design seems a bit
out of date but thankfully appearances
are just a matter of taste the skid
plate that comes in black and silver
isn't on the normal sx4
so what's our test drivers conclusion
the a Saluki thinks that the Suzuki sx4
s-cross isn't going to win any prizes
for design or sportiness but he reckons
it would be a good everyday car for
casual driving
celebrating the 25th anniversary of its
TDI engine audi presents the rs5 TDI
show car the Biturbo v6 delivers a
sumptuous 750 newton meters of torque in
addition to the regular exhaust
turbochargers the engine boasts an
electric air compressor plugging the
turbo gap the new technology will be
featured in selected audi models as of
2015 the new mercedes vito is out now
available in three different versions
panel van minibus and the crew cab combo
edition they're powered by diesel
engines with 1.6 and 2.1 liter
displacements the latter engine can also
be combined with all-wheel drive prices
and Germany started just under twenty
two thousand euros
most car makers are designing vehicles
to be environmentally friendly and low
on emissions with the a3 e-tron Audi is
taking the next step in this direction
this is the first out II model with
plug-in hybrid technology
vons ultimen her car Chester asked why
should people drive hybrid cars there
are a couple of reasons he says for one
eighty percent of drivers cover fewer
than 50 kilometers a day that's the
range of this car it's almost people
need another reason is money driving 50
kilometers in a conventional gasoline
powered car costs around four euros 50
with this car and the current
electricity price 50 kilometers costs
one year 0 75 item price fish store
liters by einem oil on feminity sent
bang gib'sea this EV button is used to
select various driving modes for example
driving on electric power alone are
driving very quietly I can also save the
battery charge or increases if I'm going
to drive around town it might be
important for me to be co2 neutral and
make less noise kind of Galatia put its
yet these are the audi a3 e-tron is a
plug-in hybrid that means you can charge
the battery at home or wherever there's
an outlet you open this here and stick
in the plot 9 stickney well in da what
is at home on a 220 volt outlet charging
takes around 3 hours and 45 minutes with
an industrial power out with it takes
around an hour and I have less Howdy's
engineers had to put on their thinking
caps to get the car to switch on the go
from its electric drive to the
combustion engine
canoes on with us in the Audi product
marketing manager Hammond phobic says
that the problem was solved by mounting
the electric motor between the
combustion engine and the gearbox as we
can see everything is quite compact
image here is the dual mass flywheel and
then the electric motor duncombe to a
machine efficient there's also a clutch
installed between the combustion engine
and the electric motor that separates
the two motors emoticon went on Conda
then there's the standard 6 gear s
tronic dual-clutch gearbox to run the
sub gearboxes plots by Tyga three
moonstones occur on electric drive the
a3 e-tron goes from 0 to 60 kilometers
an hour in 4.9 seconds with a top speed
of 1 over 30 kilometers an hour when the
combustion engine kicks in the top speed
shoots up to 220 to aldi says the model
average is 1.5 liters of fuel per
hundred kilometers the Hippolyte sarkar
tester adds another row of a detail the
whole system puts out 350 Newton meters
which makes for a relaxed driving
experience the a3 electrics each run
badging on the front and the rear is the
first difference to the other a 3 s we
notice
the situation is much the same inside
the e-tron badging chrome and matte
colors give the a3 e-tron a futuristic
feel
thank you so hospice on our tester tells
us there's also a smartphone app that
allows drivers to access card data they
can also turn on the air conditioning or
the heat on and off from outside the car
and most importantly they can see how
much juice is left in the battery here
we can see that it has 13 kilometers
worth left absolutely the trunk is
spacious despite the battery in gas tank
only the spare tire had to make way I've
been seen con queso no fanfare bake
tells us that the gas tank is where the
battery usually is it was moved back to
between the rear tires it's a so-called
pressure tensioning the fumes are
created in the tank and they need to be
vented if you're driving electrically
the combustion engine kicks in now and
then to use these fumes otherwise too
much pressure would build up in the tank
so the car can't do entirely without gas
our verdict
my father's furchester was very
impressed he was surprised how well the
technology worked although it's
extremely complex this technology has a
price tag of thirty seven thousand nine
hundred euros but he thinks that's money
well spent mala scared is all good angle
licked the Audi a3 e-tron goes on the
market in Germany in fall 2014
the cross tour is billed as an all roads
version of asset to win c5 wagon it
comes with an array of driver assists
fitted as standard and a classic set to
an gimmick often hasn't a first
impressions our car reviewer montes
finds it a bit odd the way the steering
wheel turns but the center section does
not and again if you have a collision
while going around a bend you can be
sure the airbag will deploy straight at
you meaning proper protection so it is
practical die as a song pocketed the c5
has a reputation for sound handling the
crosstour makes no secret of its weight
however that's 55 the handling as such
reflects how big and heavy the car is
montes finds it a bit sluggish the
steering response is a little indirect
although you don't feel as if it's
unsafe I've been on social casa Alba
Manhattan each task of food as long as a
case the crosstour comes with a choice
of three diesel engines the HDI 165 we
tested is the second most powerful
option generating 100 20 kilowatts and
propelling the car to 100 km/h in 9.3
seconds official fuel consumption is 5.1
litres overall montes likes the interior
workmanship some sections are a bit
sloppy like this edge of plastic
sticking out poor matt white colored
thing poking out by the fan but all in
all except for those minor cosmetic
flaws the interior works Timmy
the car's exterior look is enlivened by
fender flares long roof bars and 18-inch
alloy wheels chrome effect wing mirror
caps and brushed metal style protective
trim on the front and rear skirting add
a touch of french chick to the new sit
win the cargo section encompasses 533
litres a nice feature is the detachable
trunk lamp doubling up as a practical
flashlight the interior is uncluttered
with a pleasant touch to the materials
the driver is particularly pampered with
the heated seat also boasting a massage
function the hydro active three-plus
suspension can be raised by six or four
centimeters to boost the cars off-road
caliber albeit only at speeds under 40
km/h commitment asst isn't really
satisfied on the one hand you can raise
the body really high which is very
practical on rough terrain but with a
slightest bit of rain you can't go
off-road front wheel power means
insufficient traction ultimate unclip
add the crushed or has its strengths the
dynamic exterior the hydropneumatic
suspension and the smart assists but it
also has its drawbacks thirty-seven
thousand euro price tag in Germany means
the Citroen c5 crosstour is no bargain
but not that expensive either if a word
for the restriction to front wheel drive
the idea would be perfect stock ones not
so perfect
the cars are old but the event is young
the Schloss bends berg classics is only
in its sixth year but it's already made
an international name for itself as one
of the world's top classic and vintage
car events getting ready to start in a
Ferrari 308 GTS are dieter Costin off
and his co-driver and matching Hawaiian
shirts that's what dieter likes best
about this car is that it's in the
original condition with its original
paint it's never been tuned or altered
since it rolled off the assembly line
and it still drives beautifully the
eight-cylinder 240 horsepower engine is
the same version driven by Tom Selleck
in his TV series magnum p.i the targa
version with the removable roof victim
of conduct is a target as you understand
most name
on the first day the participants set up
on the rally historic a tour of the
hilly countryside outside cologne not
all of the cars are rarities the Schloss
been spurred classics may cultivate a
high-class atmosphere but it's no place
for snobs vintage rub shoulders with
cutting edge top of the line with coke
cars like the VW Bug that's one of the
events unique selling points the gently
rolling hills go easy on the cars and
their drivers so they've got time to
enjoy the view
you
also in the lineup is a 19 75 VW golf
known as the rabbit in North America it
was one of the very first is a go live
actor in gonna hog says the first gulfs
were built close to his birthplace after
graduating from high school he drove a
go through France and Spain to Morocco
it was a graduation present for his
then-girlfriend he says and never let
him down it brought them safely home the
Moroccan stole everything else they had
along from their cameras to their
surfboards they even had to buy two new
front wheels in Morocco it was an odd
feeling for him to be back in the same
car he once drove all through Europe and
email telling me for my really got the
vector fun that's why from the sternest
the VW Golf still promises mobility for
all regardless of class at the Schloss
benz Berg classics it holds its own with
Ferraris Porsches and Jaguar e-types
between the VW bus
and the mercedes 300sl is nearly a
million euros difference
the entries arrived at the historic
grand hotel schloss bends back most of
the drivers are not as concerned with
the times and formalities as with the
sheer fun of it
the ideal execute immediate offer
business single nayak says only the last
few kilometers were a bit tiring he felt
for himself at his golf seats were not
up to date ergonomically speaking but
they still had fun and they'd still like
to know how they placed he's not even
sure if they won or not he's armed you
fell right up he's done fuzzy New York's
and his co-drivers Ward the winners but
that's not what counts when you're on a
journey into your own past the Ferrari
308 crosses the finish line number talk
fast enough at a fabulous time he says
the route was magnificent a few cars
slowed them down so he downshifted
stepped on the gas and made a quick
seven enemies when he left them in the
dust but he had fun
the Benz berg classics perennial motto
is very important cars only one focus
this year is aerodynamics the 1938
Porsche 64 is the embodiment of the
concept many consider it the very first
Porsche and this is the only one to
survive in the original condition this
1941 tantra type 87 was another
milestone of aerodynamic automotive
design another DEATH vintage car
restorer Edwards luck explains that it
was developed using a wind tunnel back
in 1936 it was made aerodynamic above
and below the underside is completely
smooth with both front and back axles
covered by the under plate even the
engine and exhaust systems are covered
giving it a drag ratio of 0.37 20.39
extremely good for the time even if
today's cars do better it handles very
nicely reaching a top speed of 160 km/h
Edwards luck himself has driven it that
fast Texas is pinned a stronger fan with
Amato another focus this year is plastic
car bodies such as the one on the
studebaker avanti are too
capting a call Nicholas i oken but his
avanti a year ago in Palm Springs
California where it had been developed
by Raymond Irving one of the Americans
automotive industry's most famous
designers it's only got 45 thousand
miles on it and he says its condition is
like a dream the vinyl interior is all
original with its supercharged 4.7 liter
v8 it was the fastest series produced
sports car in the u.s. of the time it
has a fiberglass body and puts out a
good 300 horsepower but only with the
supercharger the body has made him a
convert buyers had to choose either the
supercharger or the air conditioner he's
got the supercharger so temperatures in
the car reached 45 to 50 degrees Celsius
he sweated but had fun anyway mechana
kumar nagendra graffia film enforce a
filthy goddamn auto i'm from gotcha
english missed a lot bascomb
you